hi I'm Callie and I've reviewed the Last
of Us part two for GameSpot I actually
have two reviews up for this game this
one is the one that has spoilers
including a major character death so if
you don't want to be spoiled for the
game don't go any further you can go to
my spoiler free review which is the
exact same review same arguments same
score just a little less detailed so you
won't be spoiled this review however is
going to go into more detail about the
game's story and further explain my
critique of the game so you can get more
context without further ado let's go The
Last of Us part 2 begins with serious
tonal whiplash one moment Ellie and her
close friend Dena are becoming more than
friends in a basement filled with weed
plants and Naughty Dog porn puns the
next Joel is being savagely beaten to
death with a golf club
it's the first of many many gruesome
deaths some happen whether you want them
to or not in intimate cutscenes that are
hard to watch while others happen just
because an NPC got in between you and
your objective and killing them was the
easiest thing to do either way that
brief glimpse of happiness at the
beginning is left very much in the dust
I hate this kid so much you want to [ __ ]
them up yeah but while the scale and
severity of death and loss in this game
is incredibly high The Last of Us part 2
is more a character study than amusing
on the nature of violence on that front
the story of Ellie her playable foil
Abbie and their quest for a revenge and
redemption is a gripping and harrowing
one and I found myself deeply
emotionally entangled with each woman
and her strengths and flaws the
bloodshed is very much a part of that
story but it's far from the most
effective one and that's where the game
stumbles a bit throughout the game I
often wanted to stop Ellie for making
the choices she was making
Joel's death sends her on a relentless
quest for revenge and I had a hard time
buying into it
alies life in the settlement of Jackson
is a good one she has a new girlfriend
and it's about as nice a place to live
as you could expect from a
post-apocalyptic community it was hard
for me at first to understand why she'd
want to risk all that for a dangerous
revenge quest when she could process her
grief among friends and loved ones in
relative safety but Ellie decides to get
revenge so you go as Ellie you play
three days in Seattle as you hunt down
any and all the people present when a be
killed Joel they're all members of the
Washington Liberation Front or WLF for
short and much of your time is spent
killing random wolves from one combat
scenario to the next you collect
resources and weapons upgrade those
weapons unlock new skill paths and
generally get very used to killing
people and infected as the scrappy agile
Ellie like I said in my spoiler free
review the combat is intense and
exhilarating Ellie's movements are
smooth enough that they almost look
scripted you can duck and dodge in a
fight and deliver a return blow with a
series of button presses that translate
into a strangely graceful dance you can
accidentally alert an enemy to your
presence only to slip through a tight
space in the wall vault through a window
and outrun your pursuer through a
building to reestablish your cover and
gain the upper hand you can also easily
get surrounded and die horribly whether
you're fighting people or infected
navigating any given combat scenario is
a puzzle in which you have to figure out
exactly how to get from point A to point
B with the resources you have I'm
partial to stealth when possible and
it's especially rewarding to decide how
you're going to silently kill each enemy
with only a flimsy silencer two arrows
and your default knife and of course it
is brutal enemies use each other's names
and cry out when you kill their friends
killing someone this dog is a priority
as they can track your scent and maul
you to death and you have to hear them
mourn the dog in real-time but frankly
the fact that your enemies have names
doesn't make them any less in your way
you have to do what you have to do to
get to the next location and you want to
do that to see where the story goes next
they might as well be anonymous at that
point overall Ellie leaves an
unbelievable amount of destruction in
her wake in just three days
day three itself ends in chaos but
before it can be resolved the game cuts
the next thing you know it's Seattle day
one again and you're controlling Abbi
this is where the last of us to
contextualizes Ellie's rampage and it's
the entire reason the story works at all
it can certainly be jarring to suddenly
switch characters in many ways you have
to start from scratch you have a whole
new set of weapons and skills to unlock
and Abby feels different in a fight but
you also know much of what happens to
Abby's friends and on day one you see a
lot of ghosts there's a pang of sadness
and overwhelming inevitability in every
interaction you have with them you wish
you could change the outcome but you
can't like Ellie Abbie was driven by
revenge and she got it through
flashbacks you learn exactly what
happened and where she's come from and
it doesn't take long to side with her
over Ellie despite any lingering
feelings you might have for Joel done
with a year's long search for vengeance
hers is a story of redemption unlike
with Ellie it's easy to get invested in
Abby's goals which includes saving her
friend and then saving some kids her
motivations are complicated sure but
it's not at all a struggle to get on
board with what you're doing
Abbie is clearly a foil to Ellie just
further along in her journey through
Abbie you get to see what redemption for
Ellie might look like even after all
that she's done it's a testament to
Abbie's characterization that I ended up
more attached to her than I was to Ellie
and when the game ripped me back to
Ellie's perspective for the final
stretch I was more concerned about
Abby's safety than Ellie's pain like
Ellie though Abbie still kills a lot of
people Abbie's main enemy is a religious
group called the Sara fights and they
too are composed of mostly anonymous
soldier types they do get some
humanization through Abby's companion
and exiled Sara fight boy named Lev but
it's about the same as that of the
wolves just enough for the story and not
enough to make you change how you fight
in Abby's case the onslaught of combat
against human enemies feels more at odds
with her character development
especially by day 3 and a lot of that
violence goes unexamined neither Abbey
nor Ellie faces real consequences for
most of those deaths for both characters
this disconnect between the gameplay and
the grander narrative is compounded by
looting and collectible hunting looting
during a fight is exciting especially
when you find the one extra bullet you
needed or a bit of health that can keep
you going but more often than not I loot
and look for collectibles only after I'd
killed every enemy in the vicinity it's
far easier and safer for one and I
didn't want to miss any of the
interesting subplots found in scattered
notes and photographs just because I
wanted to kill fewer people most of the
time there aren't any collectibles to
find in combat heavy areas but there are
occasionally notes and things to find
when enemies are around and as a result
I ended up scouring every corner of
every area in the hopes of finding
something cool because most combat
arenas give you multiple avenues of
attack and escape though I ended up
backtracking through most of them to try
to find things and that can severely
disrupt the pacing the nooks and
crannies that work well in combat just
become one more place to look for a note
or trading card and the fact that you're
looking for trading cards at all often
feels too gamey for the otherwise
sobering tone I ended up enabling an
accessibility option called high
contrast mode to help with my
collectible hunt not because it was
difficult but because I was getting
annoyed when toggled on it mutes the
background removes textures and
highlights interactable objects and
enemies
I used it after clearing an area of
enemies to speed up the looting part and
while it wasn't the most elegant
solution it did help the pacing it's one
of a litany of accessibility options -
which allow you to fine tune the
gameplay sound and visuals to your needs
it's a commendable suite that's
incredibly inclusive though I enabled an
option just to circumvent a gameplay
annoyance rather than to fit a need
despite those annoyances finding
collectables and piecing together the
stories held within them is rewarding
and paints a picture of the outbreak as
it developed through the years a bank
robbery gone wrong sticks out as a
favorite and there are quite a few other
stories worth finding a lot of the time
seeking out these collectables will
force you to get creative things like
breaking windows to bypass a lock door
or swinging on a cable to get to an area
that's just out of reach there's nothing
so difficult that you feel like a genius
for figuring it out but it does make you
feel appropriately resourceful and
smashing windows is really satisfying
it's a bleak pessimistic world and
exploration issues aside I didn't
exactly want to leave it the ending is
dead
stating and I almost wanted more time
in-game to reflect on it I instead put
the game down for a full week after I
was done so I could fully process what
had happened in the original last of us
I wanted to make Jules bad decisions
right along with him I knew it was wrong
in a sense but I wanted to save Ellie
anyway in part two I wanted nothing to
do with Ellie's bad decisions
there's no oh God I'm the monster moment
just profound sadness about all the pain
she's caused without Abby none of that
works Abby is a fantastic character in
her own right and the way the game pits
her against Ellie is what makes this
story powerful it's a tragic
heartbreaking exploration of the
consequences of the first game even if
not all your actions here have real
consequences
[Music]